uncharted co-director Neil druckmann has
revealed in a new associated press
interview that the story for uncharted 4
changed completely when he and Bruce
Straley came aboard the project the game
was originally in development under the
direction of long time series director
Amy Hennig and just enrichment who both
left the studio in early 2014 there's
some conjecture over whether hennig was
forced out but that's a points naughty
dog has been repeating druckmann and
straley previously worked on the first
two uncharted games in directorial and
design roles before co-directing the
last of us last year at a metric on
panel Nathan Drake actonel a North shed
some light on the consequences of the
changeover he said the team shot eight
months of her story and it was all
thrown away amy is still a very dear
friend of mine and she's brilliant but
the last of us guys were the next team
there so they took over and they just
wanted their own flavor they got rid of
some of the people that were involved
and just redid that thing drachman is
now indicated that the story changed to
quote one hundred percent when the pair
took over straily added we want it to be
a mind-blowing i popping sweaty palms
adventure let me know what your
expectations are for uncharted 4 and for
all the latest gaming news be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot
you